here once this and i got to write this
bit about it uh because i was making fun
of a movie and this is happening this
happened to me more than once actually
the first time i was here
is the person here
maybe
it's not i'm not mad at this person it's
a funny thing that happened i don't know
i make fun of movies sometimes but i'm
driving johnny friendly face you know
i'm not like [ __ ] up
but i'm not doing that by making fun of
movies and i don't know if it's because
it's los angeles so many people work in
movies or whatever but i think i've
gotten this more than once i'll make fun
of a movie somebody in the crowd one of
you a rogue
and in the middle of this bit that i'm
starting will go
hey you make a movie
that's happened here
you make a movie
you do it you want to talk about movies
make a movie
and honestly i refuse i don't
want to make a movie in order to have
opinions about movies
it's ridiculous that's not how it works
let's go to burger king and eat that
oreo cake that they have and you're like
this tastes like [ __ ]
the chef doesn't call it die
you make a
to talk about my cake
come back when you're up to hearing
geese buddy
you'll make a cake i can put up cakes
for cake makers hold it
you make a cake come back and tell me
about game
you don't have to make a cake even
though the surely cloud was horrible
that really happened
i don't know this